happy one-year anniversary to the switch
in these first 12 months we've seen
several Wii U games make their way onto
the new console Mario Kart 8 deluxe
Bayonetta 2 pokken tournament they've
all found new homes on the switch along
with even more ports on the horizon
but there are still great games that
deserve better than to wither away on
Nintendo's previous generation so we've
picked out 5 of our favorites that we
want to see again someday and just as a
reminder we'll be celebrating the
switch's one-year anniversary all
weekend long so join us in the
festivities and check back on gamespot
comm for more videos all right let's get
started while captain toad himself
hasn't really been bound by his Wii U's
shackles he can be found exploring the
exotic locales of Super Mario Odyssey
his troubles as a cute as hell treasure
hunter have yet to see him venture past
that system this could all change though
with a port to the switch captain toad
treasure tracker 'he's tiny yet densely
packed levels are short enough to play
in small bursts and would be the perfect
fit for Nintendo's portable console the
Wind Waker HD remake stands tall as one
of the finest games in Nintendo's Wii U
library but imagine how great it would
be on a handheld device if breadth of
the wild has taught us anything it's
that Zelda is the perfect game to play
anywhere and the wind wakers vast oceans
would feel right at home on the switch
oh and can you imagine conducting the
Wind Waker songs with the joy Kahn it's
meant to be
[Music]
while Super Mario Odyssey nearly
perfected the plumbers single-player
experience I'm still clinging to the
prospect of more four player madness so
why not bring Super Mario 3d World over
to the switch to fill that void 3d
world's impeccably designed worlds were
platforming bliss on the Wii U so a
portable version would be great for
revisiting the game one level at a time
and with the switches improved wireless
capabilities it could mean even more
hours of co-op multiplayer fun and also
yelling at our friends for tossing us
off a Ledge the wonderful 101 was a
delightfully bizarre superhero action
game and it was unlike anything we had
ever seen before there were dozens of
hilarious characters awesome giant
monster battles and an alchemy style
input method that made attacks and
combos a joy to pull off now the
wonderful 101 never quite found a huge
following on the Wii U but a switch port
could resuscitate that game and show a
whole new audience the power of teamwork
Super Mario maker was one of the Wii U's
last greatest Harrah's and thanks to its
incredibly deep level creator and what
basically amounts to an endless amount
of content people are still playing the
game to this day but porting the game to
the switch would give us the power of
creation wherever we go and could
provide a much more streamlined way of
sharing levels with our friends sure the
controls might be a little bit of a
hassle and dock mode I mean after all we
don't have the luxury of a second screen
but the idea of creating and plane
levels without having to be tethered to
a home console would more than make up
for it
come on Nintendo you know the same if
you build it we will come so those were
five Wii U games that definitely deserve
a second chance on the switch now
personally and don't tell anyone this I
still secretly love the Wii U and I
really wish that every game on that
system could make its way to the current
gen but that's probably not gonna happen
so which game would you choose to port
over to the switch Nintendo land anyone
anyone No okay
[Music]